power corrupts and absolute power
corrupts absolutely you're gonna go to
war this might be the only thing I do
with the mountain Sonny learn what it
means to be a man
the greatest gladiator match in the
history of the world
God vs Man
not a few women like you well I don't
think you've ever known a woman like me
you know the oldest line America
that power can be innocent
power corrupts and absolute power
corrupts absolutely
you're gonna go to war this might be the
only thing I do the greatest gladiator
match in the history of the world Son of
Krypton vs bat of Gotham
stay down but wanted it you'd be dead
already sunny learn what it means to be
a man
the greatest gladiator match in the
history of the world God vs Man
but now if you wouldn't like you well I
don't think you've ever known a woman
like me
you know the oldest line America
that power can be in this thing
you
hey youtubers it's Charlie so Warner
Brothers dump some more Batman V
Superman footage I just jammed them all
together a bunch of different clips and
I actually saw some really funny news
about some of the International versions
of the movie funny stuff first if you
live in India you're probably not one of
the people watching my videos I don't
think a large portion of my viewership
comes from India but if you are in India
be sure to collect a hug from everybody
else that's watching this video because
the version of the movie that Warner
Brothers is releasing there has been cut
down there's supposedly some brief
nudity in the film that prevented the
Indian government from allowing the film
to be released inside the country so
they've removed whatever naked ass was
inside the movie and it's going to be
released just like normal in India like
everywhere else in the world I don't
know if the Chinese cut is the same
usually censorship inside China is way
more hardcore than anywhere else but
apparently the rest of us are going to
see some ass they did not say what kind
of asset was going to be if it's going
to be Batman ass if it's going to be
Henry Cavill's ass if it's going to be
Wonder Woman's ass is like Schrodinger's
ass until the tights come off it could
be anyone's ass so just take your
guesses now the new stuff in this
footage that I stitched together is
mostly the same types of fights that
they've been releasing before this like
in the last big trailer from different
angles they're really doing a good job
of just hyping the movie around Batman
and Superman coming together which is
what most of the movie is about
personally I'd rather than do that then
have them market all the other stuff
like the doomsday stuff any of the
Justice League stuff they're setting up
leave some of those surprises for the
movie theater so you can hear people
screaming in the middle going oh my god
this is so great there's some other
stuff later this week they're supposed
to be doing a good morning america they
might drop some new footage if they do
anything interesting I'll totally do a
video for it but Ben Affleck actually
just did like the latest Oh mais video
and as part of the warner brothers
studio tour if you've never been to
warner brothers studio a lot they do a
tour where you can see a bunch of the
big props it's pretty cool during the DC
part he just had a little bit of fun
with people that were on the tour so
I'll play like a little bit of that
video here take this
how's the tour going good I want to see
if anyone to take a spin in the
Batmobile I want you you want to take a
spin coming up
ten bucks is all it takes to win and
every entry supports eastern Congo
initiative so click the button or go to
oma's com4 / batman and hopefully i'll
see you that's a career here's my big
question for you guys about the way
their marketing these films would you
rather than do Deadpool type stuff where
it's really tongue-in-cheek and a little
bit twisted or do you like more of the
family based marketing that the DC films
and the Marvel films typically do DC and
Marvel are both family brands when they
market Batman V Superman when they
market captain america civil war most
that's intended to be viewed by anybody
you can imagine in every single
demographic little kids old people
anybody sometimes that's bad like when
you try to make something that everybody
will like usually it ends up being less
special Deadpool i think is a good
example that you can make a film for
fans that other people will go to see
but the real reason the Deadpool is
successful is way more complicated than
that it really just gave us something
that we had not had before superhero
films for the most part have been pretty
standard DC and Marvel family-based
films so Deadpool breaking the fourth
wall being an r-rated Bugs Bunny which
is something that we hadn't seen on this
scale yet and one thing that I think Ben
Affleck has tried to change that Ryan
Reynolds already does really well is be
approachable it's a lot easier for fans
to form a relationship with someone if
they're approachable George Clooney is
like the opposite example that someone
who lives on an island is super rich
there's like this very clear separation
between him and the people that watch
his movies and I really think it helps
when younger actors engage with us on
social when they answer your tweets or
they post things that are really candid
like hey I'm just hanging out with my
family today it really helps create
awareness for the projects that they're
working on even if it's not a comic book
film I have massive respect for big
celebrities that operate their own
social pages whether it's Facebook
Twitter most of the big celebrities on
YouTube are actual youtubers not film
and TV celebrities but you get the idea
you can sense when an actor's going the
extra mile and it really even if the
film isn't as good as other films you
still might go see it just because you
like them so much here's actually good
question for you guys I don't make a lot
of videos with celebrities but if I ever
had the opportunity to what kind of
video would you want me to do I don't
really think interviews are that
interesting it would have to be either
like a prank video or so
comedy or maybe just like a tour of some
of the sets I don't have anything like
that planned anytime soon but but if the
opportunity ever does come up let me
know what kind of videos you guys would
want me to do in related news i know you
guys are bummed that the flash is on
break for a couple weeks i'm going to do
a new bonus video for that tonight if
you live in the UK though i think it
actually just started the UK and there
is new legends of tomorrow but but flash
and arrow are on break for most of the
people in the US so new flash video
coming soon well you guys wait for that
new flash video you can click here for
the flash trailer for the next episode 4
episode 16 and you can click here for my
Gotham mr. freeze video thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight